so i hope you're starting to get a
handle on
getting the 2d part in a 3d
problem let's have a look and push on
your vector thinking
a little bit further okay i'm now giving
you two
arbitrary points out in space and gonna
try and get you to remember some of your
extension one
vector stuff as well number one we're
looking for
the vector between those two points
and we're also looking for the unit
vector that's corresponding to that okay
so there's obviously two bits of
knowledge there let's see if we can
remember
now i'm going to give you a bit of a
nudge um and the nudge is going to be
with the diagram
okay so as you jot down the important
piece of information
here you obviously don't have to write
the whole question remember i said to
you doing example
one that sometimes you orient your um
3d coordinate system in a different way
just to make it more convenient to you
okay but sometimes
that 3d coordinate system is actually
not necessary
at all let me say that again sometimes
even when you're dealing with
coordinates in three dimensions
placing like coordinate axes onto there
doesn't add anything to your ability to
solve the question doesn't necessarily
make anything clearer
i think it did in this case because we
had to know where are our directions and
all that kind of thing
but here i'm going to suggest to you a
slightly different
simpler way of putting this okay let's
just take point a
and point b and literally just put them
anywhere we'd like right just
nice and separated out i have their
coordinates
four seven one and two one ten
okay now to get the vector from
a as my colors to b
i can employ some of my and i know you
guys weren't fans of this but it's
super important to actually get your
head wrapped around this we can employ
some of our 2d vector thinking
because even though a and b are in these
weird spots i can put them on the same
plane together so i can now consider
this
as an entirely 2d problem right just
conceptually
i can work out my vector from a to b by
connecting them to a
third point of reference namely
the origin right because i always know
like this
literally tells me where is a in
relation to the origin where is b
in relation to the origin okay so if you
come back to that original table
that we did right you could state for
example what is
in component form or column form if you
like what is o
a it's a trivial thing to state right it
would be uh in component form
i plus seven j plus k
that would be vector oh a do you agree
you could also
similarly state ob in exactly the same
way just the
two one and ten okay now how can i use
oa and ob to help me
get a b
what do you think kevin um
minus a huh okay hold on did you catch
what calvin just said because there's a
lot of thinking actually going on in
there
the first thing you said calvin was
let's flip o a
so o a goes from the origin to a
flipping it or
slapping a minus sign on the front sends
it in the opposite direction
makes sense so this dotted one here we
will write
as a o yes
okay now if i start from a and then go
to o
all i need to do to add on to that to
get to b is take my ob vector which i
already
have right so it's a rather indirect
path to get there but the great thing
about it is i know what ao and ob
are or at least i can work them out so
i'm going to pause right there i think
you can work those bits
out see if you can find out or
articulate what will the vector be
and then can you remember you might need
to go back to your extension 1 notes
how do i get the unit vector out of that
okay
give you a few minutes to have a play
off you go how'd you go
jalan there happy times now the reason
why i kind of dwelled
on this for a moment is that i really
wanted you to understand
where this composition of vectors came
from and i saw several of you
who kind of arrived maybe at one of
these layer or even went straight to
here okay
if that was you can i encourage you
right now to pick up your pen and write
these lines beforehand
are they necessary no but do they
clarify
what on earth you're doing absolutely
and so they're really really vital i
think to communicating
in a way that makes your working just
sort of sit in a way that makes sense
um a b by definition is a to o
and then o to b that's just
vector arithmetic putting things
together okay when i first learned this
at uni um people said to me just do this
just put your vectors backwards to the
order and then subtract one and i just
could not get my head around
why you would do that and this is the
why i hope it's
straightforward
you yeah you can absolutely define it
in this way however i think it is
important you understand why
it is defined in that way and it comes
from this definition okay
anyhow we get to the same result this is
actually one of the more basic things so
i think we're fine
how do you get from here to a unit
vector
what what is a unit vector again it's a
vector of
magnitude one right now presumably well
you can even see by the numbers this
vector will not
have magnitude one so we have to scale
it do you have to scale it up or scale
it down
we have to scale it down it's way too
long okay so in order to work out
um i think i called this v is that what
i called it yeah
so in order to get to that
v hat maybe i should have chosen a
different letter um
i have to work out the magnitude of this
vector how do i do that the
information's already on the board
maybe i'm slightly covering it a little
bit that was a spoiler okay you're just
gonna use
pythagoras like you did before okay so
when you have a look here
your lengths have all been calculated
for you already for each of the
components so you're going to do
2 squared 6 squared 9 squared what's
that give you
from memory 121 which again you can see
has been crafted to make this easy for
you
the length of this this implies the
length
is going to be 11 because you take the
square root
which means that to get to the unit
vector we're going to scale down by that
factor
of 11 and then everything else is
the same make sense one last thing
before you go
since we're in the theme of having more
than one way to do problems right
um this is the the vector way of
approaching it
but you could have also worked this out
if you're like in a quick and dirty mode
trying to get to
these numbers negative two negative six
and nine can you see just look at the
numbers for a minute
how these numbers arrive without having
to resort to some complicated
geometry to get from a to b
you're starting let's do each of the
components separately
four and then seven and then one right
by definition this vector means
you add some x vector to this x
coordinate
and apparently you end up at two yeah
and then for the y you start at seven
you add some y vector
and then you should end up at one yeah
and then lastly you start at one and
then you add some z vector
you end up at ten and hopefully you can
see pretty straightforwardly
why that actually makes sense which i
think is a really helpful thing just to
have not to solve
problems but to have in the back of your
mind so that when you arrive at a point
like this
you can do a quick sense check and say
because i actually fun fact
the first time i did this i was changing
numbers to make the question uh
nice right and i computed something
wrong and i could look at it and say no
this answer i had a number that was
bigger than 10 which is hilarious
and like that can't possibly be right
because i'm getting from 1 to 10
right so sense checks are always really
valuable